Speaker 1: All right, let's get into this
week's mailbag if you want to participate.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
Remember that we do get hundreds of emails
every day we feature about eight to 10, so
please, please, please with peace and love.
Don't get mad if yours doesn't make it on.
Let's jump right in to one that is horrible.
Unfortunately, really, really bad stuff.
Why do Jews keep getting expelled?
Asks H. Why were you people expelled from
109 countries if you did nothing wrong?
Isn't that a bit strange?
If you really think it over, if I got kicked
out 109 times from every shop in the area?
At what point should I recognize I'm doing
something wrong?
Not blaming all Jews, David, but certainly
you people are doing something wrong.
There is no anti-Semitism for me.
My friends are Jewish.
But at what point do we stop pretending that
all Jews are innocent?
Just asking questions.
This, my friends, is a bona fide, bona fide,
classic anti-Semite and I have Jewish friends.
Do I really need to say more about that one?
I'm feeling like the answer is no.
So I won't.
Let's continue a sad message from Brady.
Brady, from Indiana, says, Hey, David, my
family and I are in a bit of a situation.
All of my family have been lifetime Republicans,
but despite that, they're all vaccinated.
That's good.
But my sister is hesitant and refusing to
get it due to misinformation.
She believes the usual propaganda surrounding
vaccine misinformation and is even thinking
about taking ivermectin.
Even though we've told her of the dangers,
we've tried talking her out to talking to
her about it, but it always ends up in a fight,
her argument, and I'm kind of at a loss.
She's even thinking about quitting her job
due to the mandates.
It's also hard on the family because we usually
never argue over stuff like this.
Do you have suggestions or advice?
Appreciate it.
Love the show.
Keep up the great work.
If you could not show my email if you cover
this, that would be great.
Of course, of course.
Of course, we are not showing your email address.
We never would listen.
Here's the.
Here's the thing.
I keep going back to the Socratic method of
questioning, which is presumably her beliefs
about the vaccine being bad and ivermectin
being good are coming
Speaker 2: all
Speaker 1: from sources to some degree that
she has a similar relationship to.
She's chosen some media sources that say the
truth about the vaccine, which she doesn't
believe.
And yet she's chosen some media sources that
say things about ivermectin, which she does
believe.
And so often what I've heard from other viewers
is when you explain to them, you're trusting
sources on ivermectin with the same arbitrary
nature with with your with which you're not
trusting sources about the vaccine.
If you get them to come to the realization,
that can be useful, but it's tough.
It's very, very tough.
I don't know.
That I have real advice beyond that, but let
us know how it goes, and I'm sorry you're
in that situation, Jeffrey wrote to me and
said, David, I think sometimes you can be
hilarious when you said yesterday, I don't
know many racecar drivers and you said Butch
Earnhardt, I literally laughed out loud.
I don't agree with 90 percent of what you
say, but I watch your show every day and you
make me laugh sometimes.
Keep up the good work.
Thanks for streaming the Rittenhouse trial,
even though I'm sure it cost you in the long
run.
Yes, we are.
I appreciate the kind words we are now unbanned
from Twitch.
We were originally banned for 30 days due
to a gory exhibit that was displayed on Twitch
during our Rittenhouse stream.
They, after 11 days with no explanation, unbanned
us and we're back on Twitch and have been
streaming there this week.
So it's all.
It's all very opaque, but at the end of the
day, we're glad to be back.
Mark wrote in about the January 6th alleged
Trump rioter, who has fled to Belarus entering
the country illegally and now asking for asylum.
Mark says American and Belarus not a traitor,
David, it's Marc from Germany.
I know the GOP, as well as Trump and his supporters,
love using the terms treason and traitor whenever
it's politically convenient.
With Trump often talking about the good old
days when people were executed for treason,
despite Trump never referring, I think means
never referring to a real case of treason.
I'm now curious whether the political right
will call the Capitol attacker who's avoiding
justice by illegally entering and seeking
asylum in Belarus a traitor, too.
In my opinion, this is a perfect example of
treason.
If we follow the usual right wing narrative,
of course, the people saying law and order,
the people saying due process, the people
saying all those things should be saying wait
a second.
The Trump writer who fled to Belarus was charged
under the law, was being afforded due process,
is wrongly claiming that he's going to be
tortured and that the prosecution is illegitimate
and has decided to flee and illegally enter
a different country.
They're not saying it because they don't actually
care.
Their principles are only their principles
as far as they're convenient to them, and
when the principles are no longer convenient,
they abandon them.
But of course, mark from Germany is 100 percent
correct.
This is kind of funny.
Every once in a while, I got an email that
makes me wonder whether I've lost my mind,
Collin wrote to me when I asked last week
about, Can you help me find the show in which
I did an Alex Jones impression?
And Colin says, I think the caller is referencing
your Nixon impression from a few days back
unless I have completely lost my mind.
I have not done a Nixon impression on this
program, at least for years.
Maybe never.
And when I see this, like from Colin, who
says the caller is referring to your Nixon
impression, I start to wonder whether I've
lost my mind.
But we checked.
We looked.
I definitely didn't do a Nixon impression.
I don't know what it's all about, but it's
interesting, Bret wrote in about COVID boosters
and says, Hey David, considering how many
Americans are ordering, many Americans receive
their second COVID shot in April and May.
And it appears we need a booster shot at six
months should we expect a rise in breakthrough
cases over the next months?
Well, we don't have to wonder, Bret, we are
seeing it.
We are seeing a significant increase in cases
in the United States.
Now I just got my third dose a week and a
half ago, and I'm glad that I did.
The question has been, is it every six months
or does the third dose provide longer protection?
So far, we have good looking data from Israel,
which seems to say with a third shot, the
protection lasts longer.
It doesn't seem to start to wane at six months
now.
That's what it seems like right now.
The virus can evolve, it can change, etc.
And then a lot of these beliefs can change.
But right now, cases are going up.
And what's really crazy is there are more
people in the U.S. right now getting third
shots than getting first shots.
In other words, a bunch of the people now
showing up as getting doses are already vaccinated
to some degree.
And that doesn't bode particularly well for
our path towards herd immunity.
So that's not a that's not good.
We talked about Ron DeSantis earlier this
week, and Matthew wrote in and said, Hey David,
why should we be scared of Ron DeSantis?
He seems like a regular corporate Republican,
not a Trumpist.
At least when I see him speak.
It's just regular Republican talking points,
not necessarily Trumpist things.
I'm sure if he becomes president, I'll disagree
with a lot of his policies and sure, he's
an ass.
But why should we be scared he'll destroy
our democracy like Trump did if he became
president?
I completely, completely disagree with Matthew,
Ron DeSantis is a very Trumpian Republican.
He has a lot of Donald Trump's worst instincts
to do the opposite of what the science says
on COVID to push these big lies about election
fraud.
And he announced a few weeks ago he's opening
a commission or something to investigate.
Election fraud is like no, nobody.
Trump won Florida.
Nobody's even calling into question Florida.
He is bonkers out of his mind.
But horrifyingly, he is more competent than
Donald Trump.
So I completely disagree that Ron DeSantis
is just kind of a regular Republican.
If you look at Mitt Romney and Ron DeSantis,
there is very little in common.
Very, very not.
I'm not praising Mitt Romney.
I'm just stating a fact.
There is no comparison between DeSantis and
real non Trump Republicans like Mitt Romney,
the late John McCain, the late Colin Powell
and others.
And we've got to be very, very scared.
If Ron DeSantis is the 2024 nominee, Aaron
says about Kyle Rittenhouse, Kyle is a depreciating
political commodity, regardless of the trial
outcome.
Kyle is a depreciating political commodity
that will end up worthless after his two weeks
of fame are over.
He will never have a substantive career.
One Google search will destroy his chance
any chance he has of making anything of himself.
Well, unless it's in right wing media and
right wing agitation.
I do agree that after the not guilty verdicts
from last week, Rittenhouse is definitely
getting his 15 minutes of fame, appearing
on Fox News, being flown all around, and he's
definitely getting some fame right now.
I do agree that in terms of getting a normal
job working as if he ever actually becomes
an EMT or whatever, it seems he's got an uphill
climb ahead of him.
But I wouldn't be shocked if Rittenhouse ends
up being a successful firearms YouTuber.
I wouldn't be shocked if Rittenhouse ends
up as a C-PAC speaker in that space, in that
space.
I actually think he probably does have a future
now that he's being lionized and being made
a hero out of.
But I do think that his usefulness will be
quite limited to that.
And I'm curious to see.
I mean, by January, how many people are talking
about him?
I don't know.
We're going to wait and see.
Jeremy wrote in and said, Hey, David, can't
Joe Biden use an executive order to pass the
original $3.5 trillion dollar build back?
Better plan regards, Jeremy.
No, my research is that he cannot, and that
something like the $3.5 trillion build back
better plan needs to go through Congress.
It relates to appropriating money, and it
is not something that Joe Biden can do via
executive order.
I don't even know that I need to say more
about it because my understanding is that
cut and dry.
Very, very simple and straightforward.
If someone has a different perspective on
that, could Joe Biden?
Implement elements of build back better through
executive order, maybe let me know.
But no, my research and we have looked at
it very strongly is you can't pass build back
better via executive order.
And lastly, today, Chris wrote in and Chris
says, Thank you.
This is just like a nice message.
We don't get that many of these.
Thank you.
Hey, David, I've been watching your show for
a while.
I very much appreciate what you do.
You've consistently been a voice of reason
in the left wing space online.
It hasn't gone unnoticed that you understand
how the type of content you put out affects
people in real life.
I know it would be easy to grab more views
to put out a spicy 4G video or cover conspiracies.
But you understand that only serves to create
more doubt around the effort to save lives.
I've had a few people in my life pass away
from COVID 19, and all of them watched prominent
YouTubers or online podcasters who were quote
only asking questions about COVID and the
COVID vaccines.
You care about your audience and we can see
it.
Your work is invaluable.
Thank you.
Chris, thank you.
I really appreciate that.
And you know, it can be very easy to focus
on, like the first email that I showed you
discussing anti-Semitism directed specifically
at me, and it's great to hear from Chris.
I really appreciate that.
Remember that we are going to be off tomorrow,
Thursday for Thanksgiving and Friday for Thanksgiving.
We will then be back on Monday federal Thanksgiving
holiday here in the United States.
Everybody taking a much needed break and you
will be back with you Monday.
But before that, there's the bonus show.
If you remember it, join Pacman McCone.
Come sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can get access to the bonus show, otherwise
we'll see you back
Unidentified: here on Monday.